i saw this video yesterday um it's from
january of 2020 which obviously is right
before
the pandemic this is a survivor of the
holocaust a survivor actually of
auschwitz concentration camp his name is
marion turski and he
gives a talk we're going to show you
about two minutes of it right now he was
94 years old at the time of this speech
and he talks really about the
step-by-step
step-by-step slow progression of how you
demonize people how you other people and
how authoritarianism creeps in and i saw
this yesterday and i thought i have to
show this on the show
um it's not current events but perhaps
it's exactly current events so take a
look one day
in those early 1930s
you can read
an inscription on the benches jews must
not sit on these benches you could say
it's unpleasant it's not fair it's not
right but after all there are so many
benches around
you can sit somewhere else of course you
can
there was a swimming pool
and
over its door and inscription read
choose to enter you could say well
pleasant this is not but there are so
many places in berlin where you can take
a bath or swim so many lakes canals it's
nearly like venice
at the same time
[Music]
you can read somewhere else the jews
must not belong to german singing
associations so what all right they want
to sing they want to make music
let them just meet somewhere else they
will do their singing all right
what comes up later
is an order really more of an order than
of an inscription non-aryan children
must not play with aryan children with
the german children all right they'll
play on their own
and then you read
choice this makes your life harder but
after all
after 5pm you can still do your shopping
[Music]
are the people that carry germs that
cause pandemics
and this now
is a horror
what came later was something that
developed immediately jews could not get
jobs they could not emigrate
and then quickly
jews would be sent to ghettos
to riga to my ghetto
ashes did not fall suddenly from the
skies
it was approaching
until
what happened here behind me did happen
there's actually nothing that i can add
to that so i will only ask a question
before i end the show today which is
what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do